hello and welcome to the shiki science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about unity biotechnology
and their recent update regarding their
drug ubxo101 and the results from their
phase 2 clinical study in patients with
painful osteoarthritis of the knee
so the main takeaway from this recent
announcement from the company is that
they've decided
not to advance ubxo101 to a pivotal
study
so in this video i'll introduce to you
unc by technology
and what the company is trying to do
will then talk about
ubxo101 and the underlying biology
underpinning it
and the reason why it was used in this
trial to try and treat osteoarthritis
and then we'll look at the results that
they posted regarding their phase 2
study
and then i'll conclude by giving some
thoughts and opinions
so unity biotechnology as given by their
name
is a biotechnology company and their aim
is to develop synolytic treatments
to slow halt or reverse diseases of
aging
so the company have a few different
drugs in their pipeline
to treat symptoms of age-associated
diseases
such as symptoms of neurology in
alzheimer's disease and parkinson's
ophthalmology such as macular
degeneration
and pulmonary diseases and of interest
for this video
musculoskeletal diseases such as
osteoarthritis
so from current research a commonality
between these different diseases
is the presence of senescent cells and
the company hypothesized
that by clearing these senescent cells
they might be able to alleviate
some of the symptoms associated with
these different diseases
and so drugs that can clear or
effectively kill these senescent cells
are referred to as cenolitics but what
exactly is a senescent cell
so senescent cells refer to cells that
have undergone
cellular senescence senescent cells tend
to be a frequent occurrence on my
channel and so i've spoken about them in
more detail
in other videos but to briefly summarize
cellulosin essence is a cell phate
whereby cells no longer divide and enter
a state of cell cycle arrest
and start secreting factors referred to
as the senescence-associated secretory
phenotype
that includes inflammatory factors and
signaling molecules
the role of this secretory phenotype is
thought to mediate the
pathophysiological effects
of senescent cells whereby they can
activate
immune responses to help clear these
senescent cells
which can be beneficial in processes
such as wound healing and development
however if these cells fail to be
cleared
and they continue to secrete this
secretory phenotype
it could result in chronic inflammation
that could have deleterious pro-aging
effects
support for this comes from various
studies in particular from male studies
that have shown removal of senescent
cells have alleviated
age-associated symptoms for example in
this one study i've highlighted here
intermittent oral administration of
sonolytics
two naturally aged mice alleviated
physical dysfunction and increased
post-treatment survival by 36
while reducing mortality hazard to 65
and as i highlighted in a previous video
removal of
senescent cells in the brain have shown
potential beneficial impacts of
alleviating alzheimer's disease
associated symptoms
so the general hypothesis is that the
presence of senescent cells
and a chronic inflammatory phenotype may
be promoting these different diseases
and so by clearing the senescent cells
it could alleviate
further progression of the disease and
reduce symptoms
so this brings us back to unity
biotechnology
who are trying to develop different
cellulitic drugs
that cause senescent cells to enter a
state of cell death referred to as
apoptosis and so an ideal trait of these
drugs
is that they would be selective only for
senescent cells and they wouldn't cause
normal healthy cells to enter cell death
finding vulnerable targets
in tenescent cells is still being highly
researched and probably deserves video
of its own
so i'll only talk about the strategy
thought to underpin the activity of
ubx0101
which was unity biotechnology's drug
that they use to treat symptoms of
osteoarthritis
so ubx0101 is purported to disrupt the
interaction
between two proteins mdm2 and p53
mdm2 negatively regulates p53
by targeting p53 for degradation
p53 on the other hand is a pretty famous
protein
that does a variety of different
functions within a cell
but one of which is inducing apoptosis
so by disrupting this interaction
between mdm2 and p53
the idea is that you can increase the
activity levels of p53
and this high activity levels of p53 can
then induce the senescent cells to
undergo
apoptosis cell death so
considering that my phd focuses on p53
and cellulosin essence i was interested
when i heard about
unity's program to try and treat
symptoms of osteoarthritis by using
ubxo101
and why the company have decided to
prevent taking this drug any further
into clinical trials
so why osteoarthritis well this review
article summarizes well
the painful connection between senescent
cells and osteoarthritis
but basically research so far shows that
osteoarthritis
is a chronic disease characterized by
pain loss of cartilage and joint
inflammation and the incidence increases
with age
and so correlating with this
presence is the finding that
senescent cells in cartilage can be
isolated from patients
undergoing total knee artificial
implants and so
the evidence now seems to suggest that
it's the presence of senescent cells
that could be driving the symptoms of
osteoarthritis
and so studies conducted in mice further
support this
understanding for example in this nature
medicine paper
they used a mouse model of
post-traumatic osteoarthritis
to show that senescent cells accumulate
in this condition and that by removing
senescent cells
they could alleviate some of the pain
associated with this condition
and this pain reduction was also seen
when ubx-0101
was used as this analytic and the way
that they
gave the mice this drug was by an
intra-articular injection
and as they report the injection of 0.2
to 5 millimolar of ubxo101
produced a pro-chondrogenic environment
that indicates that
the drug was also promoting new
cartilage growth as well as removing
senescent cells
and so these promising results in mice
gave hope for the company
to test the efficacy of using ubxo101 to
treat
osteoarthritis symptoms in humans and so
a phase one trial was initially
conducted
by the company just to test the
different doses
and to test the safety and tolerability
of the drug
in addition they looked at some of the
clinical effects of taking single or
repeat doses of ubxo101
and so as with the mouse study the
patients were administered the drug
by an intra-articular injection so the
idea
is that the synalytic will only target
senescent cells in that surrounding area
instead of having a systemic impact
and so the conclusion from this phase
one trial was that
the clinical data across multiple
endpoints showed promise
of ubxo101 as a therapeutic for
osteoarthritis
and so this was also based on a
dose-dependent reduction
in the womac score which is a arthritis
index
which is a self-administered
questionnaire that asks the patients
questions
regarding pain and stiffness physical
function
whereby each of the questions are scored
on a scale of 0 to 4
whereby 0 refers to none and 4 refers to
extreme so a reduction in the weimax
score would indicate
an alleviation of the pain so with the
results of the phase one
trial the company proceeded with
starting the phase two trial
that enrolled 180 patients this time as
opposed to 35
in the phase one trial and similarly
they were interested
in seeing how administration of ubxo101
impacted patients with moderate to
severe pain knee osteoarthritis
however in the results published by the
company this week
they show that they did not see
separation of ubx 0101 treatment groups
from placebo
at 12 weeks and so i listened into the
conference call that the company
had on august the 17th where they spoke
a bit more detail about their results
and anyone can listen to that it's you
can go to their website and click on it
and what they said in this conference
call that what they saw was that they
observed a placebo response in the phase
2 study that was both
large in magnitude and long in duration
that
basically hampered the chance of
detecting an effect of ubxa101
and this is most clear by looking at the
waymax score
which is what they were using as their
primary endpoint
and so you can see in this graph here
that you've got week one through to week
12 which is when this primary endpoint
was and you can see in the different
colors placebo
and then the different doses of ubxo101
administered to the patients
and on the y-axis you can see the change
from baseline
so if you see it less than zero
effectively the
way max cross come down and so what you
can see by week 12
all of them have shown a reduction but
you also see a reduction in the placebo
and so it's hard to tell from this data
if the drug was having an impact and so
having a
placebo effect this large is also more
likely to happen when
you're using a subjective measure such
as the waymax score
however since the primary aim is to
alleviate the symptoms of osteoarthritis
alleviating the pain is something that
would be desirable in the patients
and so using the subjective score you
can understand why they use that as
their primary endpoints
and so the company said that they don't
intend to advance ubxa101 to a pivotal
study
and so this is obviously unfortunate
news for the senescence
community and for analytics in general
and raises various questions such as
whether or not
using xenolytics is the the best
approach for
alleviating symptoms for example as i
mentioned
in a previous video removing senescent
cells bad
is it that maybe the drug was working
however
maybe in the human studies there wasn't
the
promotion of replacement of the lost
cells
to enable this regrave of collagen and
so
whilst they might have somewhat halted
the symptoms
it didn't reverse the symptoms however
from the results that they've released
it's really hard to make any conclusions
on that since i've only really got the
waymax score to go by
so it was a shame to see that ubxa101
wasn't effective at alleviating pain
from this phase two trial and so now the
company are instead going to focus more
on their other analytics to help
alleviate symptoms of
macular degeneration and
neurodegenerative diseases
so it will be interesting to see what
the results are like um
when or if any of these drugs enter into
clinical trials
so hopefully this video has given you
good insight at least
of my understanding of what the company
is doing and their
phase two announcements earlier this
week and i'll be interested to hear any
thoughts and opinions that you have as
well
and so as always i hope you've learned
something and thanks for listening